Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
for
imuslim.
He relates to us here a narration
which is found originally in Muslim on
the authority of Abi
in which the prophet sallall.aii alaihi
wasallam identifies the only three ways
a person's
rewards or a person's actions or
deeds will
continue on after his death. So the
prophet sallallah.aii alaihi wasallam
tells us here if the if the human being
dies or when the human being dies all of
his deeds come to a screeching halt
and this is why we are never to ask for
death why it is such a huge and major
sin in Islam for a person to end his own
life you only get one shot in all of
eternity. This is your one shot right
here.
And so bringing that to an end before
Allah has found found it fit to be
brought to an end is throwing away the
essence of your soul. It's throwing away
your salvation.
A person's salvation can be had in a
moment.
It is conceivable that a person may live
a bad life and it turn around at the
very last moment. It's also conceivable,
conversely, that a person may live a
good life and due to an illness in the
heart that was left undiagnosed,
left un
medicated
that the person may live a good life and
follow that up with a moment's fumbling
at the end.
However, the point is is that if you
die, your deeds are done. There's
nothing else
that can happen to bring you back or
extend your deeds. A person in his
grave, if he were to collect all of his
thoughts, concentration, and power to
move his lips to sayahill,
he will not be able to. Whatever he did,
whatever he didn't do, it is sealed. At
that point, the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam prohibits us from asking for
death. He said,
[Silence]
He says, "Let none of you ask for death
before it comes to him because your
deeds come to an end when you die."
And so the point here is that life is a
blessing if a person knows what to do
with it.
Life is a blessing if a person knows
what to do with it. And very quickly on
this point,
this shows the completely different
outlook of Islam, the Quran, the Muslim
from the non-Muslim with respect to
pain.
Pain.
You go into the hospital,
you see patients that are,
you know, laying on beds. They have no
hope of recovery, but they're in pain.
So, you're urged what? To essentially
euthanize them because they're in pain.
They're in pain. Kind of an animal.
You know, if you're driving down the
road and you hit a,
you know, a deer or something. What do
we have here? And you hit a coyote.
Okay. Or you hit a a dagone
[Arabic recitation]
the sucker's still living, but it's all
busted up and it's in pain. What would
the humane thing to do be? Even what the
companions, the prophet sallallah.aii
wasallam would do, kill it, right? He
you he grabbed dad's 45 or whatever it
is and finish it off. It's in pain and
it's not being rewarded in the hereafter
for this pain. What about a human being?
You're driving down the road. You hit a
human. It's all he's all busted up.
She's all busted up. Do you put it out
of its pain?
Absolutely not. This is a human being. A
human being is being rewarded every
conscious moment of his or her life. As
a matter of fact, a human being is
potentially being report being rewarded
even in his every unconscious moment of
his life. And as we'll hear in this
narration, even after his death, the
human being is potentially being
rewarded.
And so
Allah the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
says if the human being dies his deeds
come to an end except by three things
except in three ways. The first is a
charity that continues after his death.
This is what's referred to as
meaning a continuous charity. charity
that continues to function after his
death or continues to be of consequence
after the person's death. The second
or knowledge that is continued to be
benefit of benefit of consequence
implemented after his death. Number
three, or
a righteous child that will make dua for
him. Does a child have to a child
meaning any son or daughter does that
person have to make specific dua for his
parents for his parent to be rewarded
for his good deeds? No. Every single one
of our parents,
every one of us, every one of us that
just made salah right now, our parents
were rewarded for our salah and their
parents for their salah. Even if you
didn't intend it. Why? Because Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala says,
[Silence]
And so every single good deed that we
do, our parents are rewarded for it.
Why? Because they are the one little
kids. Hey,
this is
and so
we see that every single child, every
single child of a parent, every human
being when he does a good deed, his
parent is rewarded for it. Even if he
didn't intend for his parent to be
rewarded. Why? Because you are a
consequence of the choices of your
parents.
You're an extension. I'm an extension of
my parents choices, of my parents'
actions. Person may say, "Well, my
parents didn't necessarily tell me to do
good." Yes, but you are a result of
their physical choices and so they are
rewarded because you are an extension of
your parents
and they an extension of theirs.
And this is a beautiful thing, a
beautiful aspect of our religion. Allah
is trying to give us every single
opportunity he can to get us into
paradise. He doesn't want to see us go
to hell. He gives us eight gates of
paradise. He gives us 10 times the
reward for one good deed. He gives us to
give us every single chance we can to
get into paradise. If we still manage to
find ourselves in hell after all of
that,
well, maybe that person really deserved
to be there cuz they have to really go
out of their way to go to hell.
And
Subhan Allah.